l'histoire se déroule à fort-de-france
et nul ne peut se douter qu au milieu de
ce quartier urbain la pire des misères
niche au fond d'un trou
nous empruntons difficilement le petit
tracé boueux et qui sert de chemin la
chronique llc en offrant chaque semaine
un carton de commissions aux résidents
de cette maison ou plutôt ce semblant de
bâtisses pas d'eau courante ils font de
la récupération d'eau de pluie dans ces
récipients truffé de moisissures et de
l'art de moustiques le pire la réelle
descente aux enfers c'est maintenant
âmes sensibles s'abstenir
l'état d'insalubrité du logis se passe
de commentaire et olemps avait mal de
défauts goulette
cela nous avait ni tous ceux qui payent
qu'il tousse avis pas nécessaire aucune
demande des dents d'instruction femme
aimait contact avec les services sociaux
ces deux sexagénaires semble se
complaire dans la misère
comme bon nombre de personnes âgées
ancré dans les habitudes suffisent au
bout nous avons nous pas je ne dois plus
mais est ce que est ce que vous touchez
l'argent quelque part si vous avez des
rsa on est à fond je touchais pas une
copie fut là je la vois plus tout ça est
passionnant
mais ça vous dérange pas de rester ici
je me suis habitué quoi médial alcan est
l'un des membres actifs de l'association
chrétienne crc n'ayant toujours pas de
local
c'est la direction du grand port
maritime de fort de france qui lui
prêtent un emplacement pour les deux
containers où sont stockés les denrées
et autres produits qu'ils collectent
chaque semaine pour ceux qui n'ont rien
il ya des familles qui viennent des
mères de familles et des retraités qui
sont retournés dans la précarité par
rapport à l'horaire est très cher et
donc avant la fin du mois leur argent et
puiser d'eau qu'ils viennent chercher
des web favoris aussi pour leurs
familles et on voit des mères de
familles qui viennent à clore enfin une
partie du stock certes à préparer les
repas qui sont distribués les dimanches
et jours de fête à la croix mission et
dans la mangrove du lamentin les autres
cartons organisées en fonction des
besoins de chaque famille
c'est miguel lui même qui se charge de
les livrer à domicile
selon l'insee plus de 20% des
martiniquais vivant en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
il est estimé à 615 euros mensuels